voici les lieux de Home la maison qui
tout simplement est sculptée par les
trajectoire du soleil
[Musique]
je dirais que j'en ai toujours parlé moi
de ma maison au départ je savais pas
quoi ça allait ressembler mais j'en ai
toujours parlé la maison Éric Vasseur a
inventé elle ressemble à ça c'est ton
étudiant les trajectoires géométriques
du soleil qui la pensée cette maison de
200 mètres carrés répartis sur trois
étages à l'intérieur il y fait frais
l'été et chaud l'hiver j’en
ensoleillement total pendant les quatre
points d'hiver je suis à l'ombre pendant
les quatre mois d'été il fait combien de
degrés dans la maison quand il fait 40
degrés dehors il fait environ entre 22
23 24 degrés et fait combien dans la
maison quand par exemple il fait -10
dehors avec moins 10 dehors en général
en Alsace on a le droit au soleil et -10
dehors on avait 20 22 23 degrés sans
rien la façade du bâtiment en fait n'est
rien d'autre que la trajectoire du
soleil le jour de l'été quand il est
haut